hello everybody my name is my name is
markiplier and I'm here playing the end
yeah I'm playing spongebob
Slendy pants I'm sure that some of this
is probably copyrighted to some well
hello
wait I'm actually wait a minute I can
move around alright let's get into it
before had break too many laws collect 8
pages right Mouse to turn on the
flashlight okay
looks pretty standard fare so far if I
had to guess I would say that spongebob
is incorporated into this game in some
ways and all of you know that have been
longing for this moment to arrive what's
with this rock it's not a rock earth
it's down a boulder it's a rock it's a
rock I'm actually I'm actually a big fan
of spongebob everybody's singing with me
I'm a goofy goober yeah you're a goofy
goober yeah we're all goofy goobers yeah
if you give me give me give me give er
yeah I know okay nevermind I ray you all
suck can don't no fun if it's smack you
in the eyeball alright so if all of you
remember them back to the slender
reaction compilation I sang that song it
gives me comfort when I am scared of
which I am NOT right now because well
nothing scary has happened just yet
but I'm sure that his spongebob or
Slendy pants pops out I'm sure he'll be
rightly terrified I don't know what he
looks like in this game but I'm sure
it's not good huh
well alright then
I've lost the run here it is okay what
it just look like it's a head spongebob
but he's moving
wait he's moving he's catching up to me
ah run is another one the Li Li Li Li Li
Li yeah get away get away you [ __ ] I'm
getting out of here and you're not
coming with me lately that was one of my
favorite episodes but above the one with
a flying dutchman of like a stone there
so that was only my favorite I have
completely lost the road and M totes
mcgoats
lost oh boy man spongebob was catching
up pretty quick where's the road I need
to get back on the road this is like
Slendy Tubby's ooh this pages are only
on the road I hope it it sounds like
someone wants to sell me something
oh the spongebob references are gonna be
no longer piss ahead who you called
print hood oh man the spongebob
references is bringing me back I'm gonna
have to rewatch all the episodes cuz I'm
a grown man and apparently oh man what's
wrong with my life what about doing with
my life playing games like this I hope
that I can sprint indefinitely because I
definitely don't wanna be caught between
a rock and Slendy pants what the hell
was that one's banging on my door
I've lost the road again is there a map
or some map no I am all on my own but
that's okay I don't need anybody but my
three friends the gang's all here
see I don't remember I don't know that
reference so I'm about doing math let me
find the road I can get back I lost
Slendy pants a long ways back exactly
sure where but he's no longer in the
immediate vicinity and I
sounds like more like an explosion than
something bad happening the music
doesn't seem to have picked up and oh my
god my cord is being tangled up in my
crotch
oh don't say it when that happens yeah
so much so far the atmosphere hasn't
been changing much but sure is loud
where is he where did he run off to
where did I put that seriously where is
a freaking road I haven't been able to
find the road in forever I've kind of
just been wandering around in the grass
and the trees give me something I got
four of eight I'm doing good question
mark maybe okay here's this again is
this the same one must be yep and here's
the road okay I'm just gonna follow this
road back now and hopefully be able to
find some of the other pages because I
do not know the layout of the entire
place here I'm going to be completely
lost and there is absolutely no way that
I'm gonna win on the first try yeah
alright yep
hey that bridge looked familiar I cross
that bridge earlier let's go find all of
the ones on same what I chose a page on
the ground best
as [ __ ] tabulous li loud okay this is
where I came from
[Music]
that is really really really really loud
like really loud I saw yeah ha ha sigh I
must have missed this page on the ground
before I don't know how but I did where
was it oh here it is got it give me
giving you I didn't even read it I never
get the reader decide my favourite part
I love to read ugh oh my one look
spongebob references I wonder if we're
going to Sandy's house oh no never mind
I've already been this way I need to
cross the river again because I know
that I found like four over here I just
need to find the other four on our three
more on the other side somewhere there
was another branching path that I could
have taken or I'm wrong and they're just
everywhere okay here's a bridge wait no
did I cross this bridge wait is this the
same bridge wait a minute did I just go
[Applause]
he's right behind me he's quick he is
quick now I am boned probably I don't
think I'm gonna survive this one no
because I'm back here again op this is
the end of the road
we've gotta get me
ah Patrick what am i Oh stupid no I'm
Texas what's the difference yeah I can't
do is laughs I'm all out of Sponge Bob
references I need to get back across the
river because I know that's where the
other pages are herewego and then I need
to take a left and then don't go back
over the hill no wait I need yeah I need
to take a left left left right and then
the other pages should be here somewhere
no The Rock damn it Rock I swore because
once something was right behind me I'm
really like I thought something tapped
my chair I was like oh was that all
right then if you guys saw anything on
the webcam you'd tell me right
you wouldn't let me die a horrible death
from Slenderman stick around time why
why what I ran out of times and when
there's your a time of a fine bye
you know what screw you back to Maine
many how do I even click on that there
we go
I'm up late I'm gonna play the glowstick
mode oh yes not the glowstick mode is
bad because I only have a glow stick I
don't have a flashlight ah well this
this is this isn't any better this is
much worse this is much worse I don't
see how this is gonna help me at all I
can't even keep track of the road at
this point this is this is this is off
okay escape from Bikini Bottom I didn't
know that Bikini Bottom was that much of
a high five security facility or that
bad to begin with it seemed like a nice
place to live besides all the disasters
rocked by Sponge Bob and his antics if
you bought it I'm never gonna find
anything because I know that some of
them I've got to be deep in the woods
and I can barely keep track of the road
oh is this any better
this sucks I can't even like drop a glow
stick it's just it's just pitch
blackness this doesn't help me at all
I'm not even gonna see him when he
climbs up behind me and does his karate
all over me I literally cannot see
anything I am totally in the fog hello
this is new wait a minute there weren't
cars
Wow I saw him let us run away now
I'm totally boned in 10,000 different
ways because I I am totally lost - wait
is that the waterfall wasn't there one
at the top of the waterfall I think
maybe possibly I think maybe maybe maybe
maybe yes where is he I don't Sam fine
you know I'm out run right into my wand
I got signee pants whoops yo ass well
that's boring you are Patrick
oh you must find all eight pages but
beware looking at Slendy pants too long
will kill you if you take too long to
find all the pages you will suffocate
collect pages by pressing E what alright
I have a few things to say Slendy
Tubby's was good just because the
concept was so unbelievably creepy and
it was kind of interesting it's
interesting it is it's it was it's great
and it could use some work but at the
same time it just feels like you took a
generic slender map and just through a
model of Spongebob in there
and didn't do anything else so I mean I
wanna I wanna like it but at the same
time I can't say it's even remotely near
a good slender game even as a parody of
a slender game because it's just it's
kind of funny and I love spongebob but
ah I don't know maybe I'm being overly
critical it was still it was still
startling at some point but I I feel
like ah I don't know I would really know
I don't know what I'm saying either way
you guys try it out for yourselves let
me know what you think I'm all done here
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos in
I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
God
[Music]